so i've always wanted to be a wife and a
mom which is why
um a year ago when my boyfriend proposed
to me i was so excited
but five months till the wedding which
the wedding was supposed to be tomorrow
he told me that he was having doubts and
wanted to postpone the wedding
he couldn't really tell me why or when
he wanted to postpone it to
so i ended up just calling it off he's
trying to he's been trying to contact me
here and there
but um i haven't been really responding
so i was just wondering
why he wants to keep me in his life but
not commit
you want this from the male perspective
yes i specialize in that state
let me highlight you with exaggerated
you specialize in
what in the mail
perspective survey said survey said
you've been failing at that more than
anybody else
but wait let's hear what he has oh
yes that's why i'm asking because i've
been one my whole life
see you said the key to this whole thing
at the beginning
you've always wanted to be a mother
and a wife you
doesn't this sound like what we said
last video me and my boyfriend met two
years ago
at a party we've been inseparable ever
since
we moved into a beautiful house we had
all these dreams of like getting married
i want kids
but now we've been living in this house
for a year and
it's still no ring steve you had all
these dreams about getting married no no
boo boo
you had dreams
soldier boy no no no no it's impossible
it's impossible that we agree
so
there's no doubt he loves you he does
love you
so what did what do men do when we love
you we try to give you what you want
so you want to be a mother and a wife
will you marry me okay cool
so when he proposed you were ecstatic oh
yes you cried
he he did it the right way he put some
thought in it
huh i'm gonna cry
okay no don't do that huh
this this is just hey steve they say
how old is he 27. yeah see he
he just ain't ready whoa wait a minute
wait
no no steve no
no oh hell no
this is all you got to say if you want
me to continue
the way this is i need a ring and a date
if not i am going back to where i come
from
and when you want me you come and get me
that's all it is
oh no steve
cause the other dude was oh
hell no no now you want to know
why he keeps contacting you because he
wants you in his life
how long have you all been engaged um it
was
well we were engaged for seven months
okay cool that's that's short
what would it hurt you to be engaged for
a year and a half
so i'm just saying before you throw this
good guy away
i just want you to think for a minute
what you're tossing out the window
because it ain't going just your way
right he didn't say he never wanted you
he just got cold
feet i need a ring and a date a ring
and a day oh
this is why i say keep your receipts i
think steve harvey just uno reversed
himself
this is impressive he tripping and let
me tell you
why he tripping you ready for this right
here yes
does he have the job of his dream no
hello does he have the money saved to
give you everything you want
no hello is he ready to raise a family
and does he have the money
no listen to me when i'm until a man
okay this lesson is good women
have a biological clock
where women like to have certain things
done by a certain age at a certain time
it's your plan it's your business some
of you want to have children before 30
some of you want to be married and all
like you and it's perfectly fine
for you to want what you want men don't
have a biological clock we have a
financial clock
and his is ticking and he don't have it
together yet
and he does not see a way that he can
provide
protect and take care of you he don't
see the clear path so now he gotta back
up
man what i'm gonna give her she want
this baby what i'm gonna buy him
where we gonna live what kind of
conditions we got
all i had on this ring i ain't got no
more money
so you gotta wait you gotta let this guy
catch up
so he can get himself together because
until we determine
who we are and what we do which
affects how much we make we are very
incomplete as
men and if you want to sign up for that
you'll sign up for the 24 year old steve
harvey
right which should not have been
anybody's husband
cause i didn't have it together at all
what you all should do
is sit down see if you all can talk it
out
help support him see if you can help him
get to where he want so you can get to
where you want
that's the best suggestion
oh you happy yes i think i think that
every time preachers pissed off you you
a little bit more
like closer to happiness huh yes yeah
you just
yes i do did you say yes i do was it the
wedding
yes i did this how you doing preach you
all right
you like that no okay
servant said this probably is some
[ __ ] abba
yes yes okay um
i mean i know you keep your receipts but
this
why why you gotta do me like that it
seems like steve
can give sound advice but the moment
he's surrounded by a bunch of women
all of a sudden he starts shucking and
driving i mean it's mind blowing the
turnaround
the in the other video i had a feeling
that he was about to give
an advice i was like oh and then he
dropped it man but this
how is it different from the maybe
because the guy in the other video was a
little bit older and maybe he had his
money but but you don't know his life
circumstances in this situation yeah he
didn't even
have time to tell us that's right he
didn't he didn't get to tell us before
the other girl interrupted him
so we will not know yo the girl the
girls
asked one question and they went off i
tell her all the time you know i'm just
i'm enjoying the moment right now we're
building a bond together you know i'm
from l.a of course i don't have a lot of
you know um great positive role models
that are married in front of me
we're building because you know
right away if you want to marry somebody
especially at your age
and steve didn't say no so it's
interesting because
the other video he's suggesting coercion
now he's saying patience and i
i think the flip is very interesting and
um
i guess basically the lesson today is
like don't change the way you behave
just because you're around
women you know i mean don't change your
values and your opinions just because
you're on lakes
i think steve was probably trying to
keep his job he knew he had to appeal to
certain demographic
so he said what was necessary but
anybody who comes to me and says
i tell her all the time you know i'm
just i'm enjoying the moment right now
we're building a bond together you know
i'm from l.a of course i don't have a
lot of
you know um great positive role models
that are married in front of me
we're building a bond i'ma stop you
right there go ahead because you know
right away if you want to marry somebody
especially at your age
yo steve is a stand-up dude he's got mad
values i look at these videos and i'm
like
they were shot in the same year and he
says the complete opposite that's quite
the turnaround for the same
situation so that's pretty much all i
wanted to say for this
steve be more consistent because survey
said
you gotta be [ __ ] up
[Music]